welcome back we were so excited to find
out that you were returning for zombies
- Megan Donnelly you are so great as
Addison in the first movie we are so
pumped to see you and Milo back in
Seabrook who changed the world through
cheer but we got to wondering are you
and your cast mates really high school
students and we know that we shipped
Addison and Zed but who are you two
dating in real life we want all the
deets
you can stir the masses surprised we
love the entire cast of zombies - and we
have their real ages and relationships
lined up for you so don't go anywhere
you won't believe who meg Donnelly is
rumored to be dating in real life
Milo Manheim the star of the zombies
franchise is zombie Zed he's a football
playing zombie who was totally in love
with Addison well how would you know
you're perfect
Milo Manheim is 18 years old in real
life he used to date holiday Kregel but
they split in October of 2018 there have
been rumors that he is dating he's
Dancing with the Stars partner alexis
friend the two are definitely close but
neither of them had confirmed a
relationship Emilia McCarthy we know her
best as the Seabrook High cheerleader
lacy she eventually comes around and
decides the zombies aren't that bad this
isn't good Becky what are you doing
Lacey is played by Emilia McCarthy
Emilia is definitely not a high schooler
in real life she is 22 years old Emilia
has been acting for a while she is
currently single and focusing on her
career it looks like she is dated in the
past but she keeps her private life
under wraps
Chandler Kinney one of the new cast
members is Chandler Kinney
she is playing a werewolf named Willa
Chandler has been on the Lethal Weapon
TV show
you'd be surprised she also appeared in
one episode of Girl Meets World
in real life Chandler is 19 years old if
Candler has dated anyone she has
certainly kept her private life private
there's no news about any current or
past relationships
Carla Jeffery Addison's BFF brie is
returning for zombies - brie was an
aspiring cheerleader who became
Addison's friend in the first movie
she is played by Carla Jeffrey she might
look young but Carla is actually 26
years old Wow
we never would have guessed carla has
managed to keep her personal life a
secret so we don't know if she's
involved with anyone right now
Pierce Josa next is another new
character Pierce Joseph plays Wyatt one
of the werewolf's who comes to Seabrook
you might know Pierce as Spider Johnson
from the TV show MEC expore you know
what maybe it's friendly I'm sorry I
shot at you he was on the show for two
years
Pierce is just 17 years old in real life
that's right he is one of the Seabrook
High students who is currently of high
school age Pierce is currently living
the single life
Trevor Tordjman you know him as Bucky
from the first zombies movie he was the
head cheerleader and he hated zombies we
like to remind some bees that we don't
accept freaks in this town his character
was also Addison's cousin which made
things even more complicated
Trevor Tordjman is back in the second
movie Trevor is on a Canadian TV show
about dancers called the next step for
over 120 episodes in real life Trevor is
23 years old he is currently single
Kingston foster dad's little zombies
sister is doughy we loved her character
and we were so glad she finally got the
dog she always wanted very oh we can't
wait to see her again in zombies -
Kingston is just 9 years old she is
certainly getting more and more awesome
roles since she's so young Kingston
definitely is not dating anyone here so
excited to see her grow up and do
awesome things
Kylie Russell Eliza is one of Zed's
awesome zombie best friends and she is
one of the best characters in the movie
yeah we would have cleaned that the
teachers territorial about his mom Eliza
is played by Kylie Russell she has been
a Disney Channel star for a long time
she appeared in the original movie jump
in way back in 2007 she is 23 years old
in real life Kylie has been dating
Samuel hoser since 2016 and they are
seriously couple goals James got free
Zedan Eliza's other BFF is Bonzo and we
just love his character
Bonzo is played by James Godfrey you
might also know him from the Disney
movie the swap zombies was James first
real big role and he did great he's no
teenager like his character James is 22
years old he is currently not dating
anyone
Jasmine Rene Thomas Stacey was one of
the cheerleaders in zombies and she's
back in zombies - Stacey is played by
jasmine Renee Thomas plain Stacey was
her first major role she's too initiated
she is 25 years old
Stacey is trained as both a dancer and a
gymnast she started lessons when she was
just two years old if Jasmine is
currently dating anyone she is keeping
it on the down-low Arielle Martin the
third werewolf is a winter and she is
played by Arielle Martin you might also
know her as baby Arielle she got her
start as a singer on the musically app
and gained a huge following how you get
40 million people following you I mean I
honestly don't you also played drew on
the brat shows chicken girls and baby
dog records Arielle is just 18 years old
in real life she is dated Blake gray and
Zack Clayton but she is currently single
meg Donnelly Addison is everyone's
favorite cheerleader he just loved her
character this is our revolution okay it
doesn't have to be cheer though she is
played by the talented Meg Donnelly meg
has also been acting on the show
American housewife for the last three
years Megan is 19 years old she's very
private about her personal life but
there are rumors she is dating Logan
pepper
she is also real life besties with her
co-star Milo Manheim who is your
favorite character from zombies let us
know in the comment section you've been
the alpha for so long Willa it's hard to
imagine you letting go of the position
without a fight but luckily you didn't
have to step down as number one you had
your doubts about Addison from the start
but she proved you wrong in the right
kind of way you might come off as mean
and tough but Willa your bark is worse
than your bite we hope to see more of
you in zombies 3 if that ever happens
perfect zombies - had a fresh storyline
an amazing soundtrack and a pack of new
and wild characters the Disney Channel
sequel had it all movie mistakes
included we have 10 mistakes from
zombies - lined up for you but before we
start we'd like to point out that this
video contains some major spoilers so
keep watching at your discretion if
you're all up-to-date watch until the
end to find out which huge mistake
disproves the alpha wolf legend when we
first meet Addison and zombies she's
ashamed of her natural hair color
causing her to cover it up with a wig
but by the end of the film she's ready
to come clean about her hair color so
she takes off her wig that's when we see
that Addison's hair is collarbone length
however come zombies to Addison's hair
seems to have grown 3 times as fast as
it should have
zombies - picks up at Seabrook high
after a groundbreaking semester so
basically only a semester has passed
since we first saw is that and Addyson
fall in love on the small screen but if
that's the case how did Addison's hair
grow so quickly according to health line
hair grows an average of 6 inches every
year but Addison's grew over 6 inches in
just under three months since Addison's
hair is very different than everyone
else's it may grow at a faster rate
however this was never explained and
it's being seen as a continuity error
when the town of Seabrook finds out that
werewolves are real they panic and
choose to restore the monster law half
of the town is put under curfew while
the other residents are too afraid to
leave their house Willa and her pack
choose to sneak their way into Seabrook
High where they can locate the
white-haired alpha in the morning but to
do this they have to keep a low profile
or else they risk getting caught the
pack dances their way into Seabrook High
where they take refuge and event great
office is near but this scene had a few
mistakes that didn't go unnoticed by
eagle-eye fans first of all how did
Willa Wyatt winter and the pack get into
the school last time we checked schools
were locked at night especially during
monster curfews and most curiously how
did the entire pack managed to fit
behind an air
vent in the hallway seeing the wolves
walk into the vent was like watching
clowns casually stroll out of a clown
car focus remember were fierce midway
through zombies - Zed catches Wyatt and
Addison sharing a special moment which
leads him to say things he doesn't mean
according to Zed werewolves they're not
interested in fitting in and according
to Addison the Zed is trying to fit in
so badly he's forgetting who he truly is
Zed lashes out on Addison says the girl
who wore a wig her whole life
this leads to a heartfelt duet called
gotta find where I belong which is sung
by Zed Madison who have just fought for
the first time but something a little
strange happens during this duet we see
Addison walking through a hallway
wearing her cheerleader uniform but
seconds later when she turns to corner
and walks out of school she's wearing a
light blue outfit instead while it's
normal for outfit changes to occur the
song seemed to be unfolding in real time
causing viewers to raise an eyebrow or
two at Addison spontaneous new outfit we
spotted more than one mistake in it
gotta find where I belong but more on
that later
come with us what's so important it's a
well-known fact that werewolves and
silver don't mix however there are a few
inconsistencies surrounding this ancient
fact in zombies - while walking through
the Seabrook High trophy Hall willow
winter and Wyatt reveal that wolves
aren't scared of anything silver but
then you can see a werewolf in the
background grab hold of a silver trophy
and start screaming when it burns his
hands this doesn't sound like something
a scared werewolf er do so we figured
that Disney wanted viewers to know just
how detrimental silver could be to
werewolves problem is near the end of
the film the wolves are handcuffed to
have to bring sprayed with a thick veil
of silver smoke Dale reveals that he
sprayed them with collodial silver and
claims that it will tame them which it
does but here's the problem why didn't
the silver smoke burn the Wolves like
the trophy did being sprayed by a liquid
with silver attribute should have given
the Wolves some serious burns but it
never did if it's gonna hurt the
werewolves you have to stop it you're
right when we first reunite with Zed in
Addison they revealed that Seabrook and
zombie town have united forces to create
a brand new civilization however
everything
apart when it's announced that
werewolf's are on the loose Seabrook
chooses to reinstate the monster law
preventing zombies from going to prawn
and upholding their human rights but
wait did anyone else think it was
strange that Willa and her pack were
accepted into Seabrook High with open
arms
despite the monster law still being in
effect this is not about politics I
always just felt like chair could unite
we mean the whole reason the monster law
was reinstated in the first place was
because werewolves were in town and yet
they were allowed to join the school no
questions asked
it just doesn't add up what's even
weirder is that principal Lee didn't
even get a choice in the matter
Addison and coach decided to welcome the
wolves without ever consulting her how
could monsters join the local high
school when the monster law was in full
swing can you explain this movie mistake
sound off in the comments Brie's
Addison's best friend and she has a huge
crush on Bonzo who likes her back
problem is Bonzo doesn't seem to speak
English whereas Bree shouldn't be able
to understand a word coming out of
Bonzo's mouth but as it turns out Bonzo
and Bree have no problem communicating
during zombies - Zed suggests that
seabrooke hi teach the students how to
speak zombie it's amitabh second
language good so we know that it's not
on the curriculum so how does Bree
understand the zombie language she could
have learned how to speak zombie on her
own since she does have a crush on Bonzo
but how did she master the language so
quickly when Bonzo asks Bree to attend
the prom with him she says yes without
missing a beat did anyone else find this
strange keep watching for the biggest
mistake in zombies to Addison Zed and
the wolf's go to extreme lengths to save
the moonstone from being destroyed in
the power plant explosion
sadly the seabrooke power plant
accidentally explodes after they win the
fight the wolves are immediately
affected and many of them fall ill when
Zed visits the Wolves hideout he sees
firsthand how the explosion is affecting
them many of them are so sick they can't
even stand they were wrong to destroy
zebra power but this rule doesn't apply
to Willa and Wyatt
despite their powers coming from the
same energy source Willa and Wyatt are
seen standing upright and helping their
pack mates
still they decide to go to prawn and
have
a good time this plot hole isn't super
obvious but the more we think about it
the less it makes sense wouldn't Willa
and Wyatt be just as sick as the other
Wolf's and why would Willa who has seen
as the alpha leave her pack behind when
they need her the most earlier on in
this video we mentioned that there was
two mistakes in the duet gotta find
where I belong the first one revolves
around Addison spontaneous outfit change
and the second one takes place near the
end of the song when day turns to night
in the blink of an eye Addison start
singing the two-minute song while she's
still at school but by the time the song
comes to an end it's dark outside could
it be that Zedd and Addison's - it
defies the hands of time like their
relationship defies social standards
even one protesting for what's right it
sure seems like it
or perhaps time isn't as linear in
Seabrook as it is in real life this
could explain the time jump that takes
place and it gotta find where I belong
as well as the mystery behind Addison's
hair growth one of the biggest mistakes
in zombies - revolves around the magical
moonstone throughout the sequel willow
reveals that without the moonstone
werewolf's will stop existing however
when the moonstone is destroyed in the
power plant explosion the werewolves
fall ill instead of disappearing but the
biggest mistake of all is exposed when
the moonstone reveals itself to Addison
and the wolves midway through pron the
students find out that the moonstone has
not been destroyed
the wolf's are then able to recharge
their crystals and cure themselves but
if the moonstone was never destroyed in
the first place why did all the wolves
get sick at the exact same time it could
be that the placebo effect came into
play the Wolves thought the moonstone
had been destroyed so their bodies
tricked them into feeling sick what do
you guys think was this a major plot
hole or not
Zombies to was amazing but there's a one
last mistake that we just can't shake
and it has everything to do with the
legend of the great Alfa ever since the
Wolves saw Addison's white hair at the
beginning of the movie they believed her
to be the great alpha you are a leader
Addison but if something a lot greater
than sheer according to them there's a
prophecy that states that an alpha
werewolf will lead the wolves to the
moon stone however when Addison finally
tries on the werewolf necklace it
doesn't light up for her so basically
she's not a werewolf still she is the
one who led the wolves to the moonstone
so if Addison isn't the alpha wolf
there's a huge mistake surrounding the
legend of the great alpha I thought
everything would make sense if I was a
werewolf could it be that Addison really
is a werewolf but that zedzee ban
supercharged her necklace preventing it
from lining up or could the prophecy be
wrong sound off in the comments and be
sure to tell us if you've spotted any
more mistakes in zombies - they dig more
monsters we are monsters we hate to say
it but we're disappointed in you Bucky
you're supposed to be a leader but you
run and hide whenever things get spooky
we thought you had put your zombie
bullying days behind you but you were
back to the same old shenanigans and
zombies - you might have allowed zombies
to join your cheer squad but that hasn't
stopped you from sabotaging and
segregating them we know you're a nice
guy deep down Bucky but we're still
waiting for you to prove it
zombies - welcome to a brand new
soundtrack and a band of unique actors
to the franchise with so much going on
it was easy to miss out on some fun
tidbits and background information we're
about to dive into zombies - and reveal
the 15 things everyone missed if you
haven't seen the sequel yet keep in mind
that this video contains some major
spoilers you've been warned
I'm sorry we got this is the first song
we hear in zombies - Addison and the
cheerleaders sing it while completing a
huge obstacle course at cheer camp and
Zed and the zombie friends join in while
dancing through zombie town but if you
hit pause ones head and the zombies are
dancing in front of the movie theater
you can see that night of the werewolf
is playing at the cinema is this a
coincidence
probably not what's even more curious
however is it the sign next to it is
blurred out could this be the title of
zombies 3 watch until the end to find
out I'm so excited to see well Zed's
little sister Zoe loves animals more
than anything so we weren't surprised
that she was excited about the werewolf
threat instead of being afraid
Zoe even put up a poster saying that she
wanted a werewolf friend that's when Zoe
crossed paths with Wyatt who was posing
as a human after chatting with Wyatt
Zoe realizes that he's not who he's
pretending to be Zoe makes remark about
the size of Wyatts eyes which look huge
behind his glasses Zoe says what big
eyes you have which is a reference to
the European fairy tale Little Red
Riding Hood if you notice this reference
leave a wolf emoji in the comments it's
no secret that Bucky
doesn't like zombies he's made that very
clear but during the musical number we
got this we see just how far Bucky will
go to humiliate and harm the zombies at
his school in a blink and you'll miss it
moment we see Bucky blasting a Z Team
cheerleader with his bug-zooka which is
like a bazooka but with water
we knew that Bucky was mischievous but
we never thought he would physically
harm his cheerleaders the look on the Z
team's faces says it all Bucky had a
bug-zooka made to sabotage the Z team
but they won anyway dirty
every sports team needs a mascot which
is why no one batted an eye at the
Seabrook high mascot shrimpie but things
get a little weird when it was real that
shrimpy also doubled as a bus driver
clearly shrimpy had some issues keeping
his eyes and bus on the road instead of
slamming on the brakes when he saw Zed
on the ladder he hit the zombie and kept
driving
shrimpie did not stop driving until the
bus collided with a fence in the
Forbidden Forest so basically without
shrimpie the werewolf's would never have
seen Addison and entered Seabrook
without shrimpy zombies too would not
have been possible
shrim pees days as a bus driver are
numbered he put everyone's lives at risk
when he failed to bring the bus to a
stop during his rampage we see shrimpie
collide with a fence and on the fence is
a sign that reads Forbidden Forest keep
out afterwards we find out that this
fence was stopping the werewolves from
getting outs for the zombies and humans
from getting in but did you notice how
small this fence was what was stopping
the almighty werewolves from jumping
over the fence before shrimpie took it
down and who put up the fence in the
first place there's a lot of mystery
surrounding the Forbidden Forest and
we're hoping to find out more about it
should the franchise add a third
installment did any of you notice how
huge the moon was when Willa and her
pack surrounded Addison in the forest
not only is the moon huge and dark but
it's also present despite it being light
outside could this at bizarre moon be
what powers the moonstone in the first
place and why can this moon only be seen
in the Forbidden Forest
obviously Seabrook is a town unlike any
other so anything is possible anyway who
cares what they think
it's a terrible town ever since zombie
town was allowed to open its gates tons
of new shops have popped up all over
town there's the Night of the Living
Dead store and a crystal shop to
Seabrook has come a long way since the
first zombies movie but they still have
a long way to go
after watching zombies - we know that
the zombies and werewolves inherited
their special powers from magical
crystals however Crystal shops are
usually run by witches could
this crystal shop be hinting towards
Amba stre introducing the witches of
some sorts what other new stores did you
spot in zombie town and Seabrook tell us
in the comments the dog ate my homework
is one of the oldest excuses in the book
it's a joke that's been used plenty of
times and it popped up in zombies too in
the most subtle of ways when Wyatt is
following Addison in the library the
camera jumps to Bree who is doing your
homework but then winter pops up behind
her rips out a page from her binder and
eats it now we all know that winter can
go a little overboard with their
intimidation tactics but who eats paper
well a dog does we hope Brees teacher
believes her when she says that fans of
the first zombies film were quick to
point out that the zombies all had the
letter Z in their names while some
zombies like the Zed and Zoe start their
names off with the letter others like
Eliza and Bonzo simply have a Z inside
of their first names well in case you
didn't notice the werewolves follow a
similar naming pattern as the zombies
Wyatts Willa and winter all have names
that start with the letter W but the
first letter of their names isn't the
only thing that can be linked back to
their werewolf backgrounds Willa and why
it's last name is like Henson which
derives from the word Lycan and Lycan is
a term used to describe a humanoid wolf
it's pretty common for high schools to
have huge budgets when it comes to
sports but Seabrooks cheerleading budget
is out of this world not only is the
town about to knock down Seabrook power
to make room for a new cheerleading
platform but it also hosts a yearly
cheer camp the obstacle course we see
during the song we got this must have
cost the town thousands of dollars to
build if not more Seabrook High has a
huge budget when it comes to
cheerleading
every adult knows that they have to
watch what they say around children kids
can easily pick up on bad words and
repeat them without fail we saw this
happen when Addison was brought to the
den of the wolf when Addison is
attempting to howl she says a bunch of
hilarious things but at one point why it
stops her to remind her that there are
where pups around winter points out that
Addison needs to put a pebble in the
swear wolf jar but the damage has been
done
all of the young wolves mimic Addison's
swear word at the exact same time did
you catch this hilarious joke she needs
to put a pebble in the swear wolf jar
that and Bucky go head-to-head for the
chance to become the school president
they sing the catchy song I'm winning to
show the crowd why they deserve to win
during the song things get a little
personal Bucky points out that Zedd is a
monster who can't control himself
Bucky believes this to be the reason why
he should be elected school president
instead of Zedd bud Zedd fires back
without a second to waste when Bucky
points out that Zedd eats brains Zedd
says that Bucky has nothing to worry
about since he has none zette called
Bucky stupid to his face and it flew
right over his head did you catch this
hilarious insult there's both good and
bad karma depending on what you put out
in the world
unfortunately for Zedd he did something
bad and received a huge dose of karma
within minutes when Zedd finds out that
Addison might be a werewolf he steals
her necklace to stop her from
transforming but obviously this wasn't
his choice to make
after winning over the crowd during the
presidential debate Zed's zband
clashes with the crystal necklace which
results in said going full zombie on the
crowd because of this Zedd loses the
crowd and Bucky becomes the student body
president if Zedd hadn't stolen
Addison's necklace he might have won
against Bucky I lost the election
[Music]
the werewolf's might look like high
school students hence why they were
welcomed to join Seabrook hi
but these sly wolves are not who they
appear to be Willa
Wyatt winter and their pack are a lot
older than Addison zed and company they
don't age like zombies and humans do at
the beginning of the movie winter says
that once they locate the moonstone
they'll be able to live wolf's strong
for another 100 years
turns out the moonstone also provides
anti-aging properties and what do we do
we can recharge our necklaces and stay
wolf strong for another 100 years if you
thought the zombies franchise was over
and done with
think again although the Disney Channel
has yet to confirm a three pole it's
obvious that something is in the works
after all zombies too did end with a
cliffhanger we still don't know which
group Addison belongs to she's not a
human or a zombie or a werewolf if we
had to guess
zombies three would finally reveal
Addison's true heritage
Addison's white hair was glowing bright
blue at the end of the sequel and a blue
meteor was seen falling from the sky
there's so much left to the story and we
can't wait to find out which new couples
linked up in Z 3 did anyone else notice
the chemistry between Eliza and Wyatt
sound off in the comments the highly
anticipated sequel to Disney Channels
zombies finally aired on February 14th
2020 Sambi stew was a lot of fun with
new songs and great new characters wanna
know how Milo Mannheim and Meg Donnelly
felt about that on-screen smooch keep
watching to find out all the
behind-the-scenes secrets we have a
brilliant and cheer tested candidate
running for president this year building
a movie is hard work actors spend long
hours on set during filming they have to
film each scene several times to get it
absolutely perfect it's even more
difficult when there are lots of huge
dance numbers like in zombies - even
though filming was a lot of fun for the
cast they had to work really hard after
a full month of rehearsals they started
filming what a lot of the movie happens
at night
after all there are werewolves and
zombies in Seabrook they aren't known
for hanging out during the day many of
the night scenes took hours to film even
if they were only a couple of minutes
long this led to overnight filming
sessions the cast would be up all night
and sometimes the cast too just hung
around at night if they weren't in those
scenes they really just enjoyed being
with each other meg hung out when she
wasn't needed on Trevor Tordjman 's last
day on set but there are a lot of
daytime shots too how did the cast
manage to catch some Z's
[Music]
Milo Manheim plays the world's greatest
zombie as Zed he's a great friend
athlete and big brother he's also a
really great dancer
Milo impressed everyone with his dance
moves in the first movie but then he
impressed the rest of the world when he
appeared on Dancing with the Stars in
2018 Milo was paired with professional
dancer Witney Carson the pair came in
second place on the show
Milo showed off his new dance moves
behind the scenes of zombies - according
to Megan his other co-stars he saw says
every five seconds it's great
meg told j14 magazine that she thinks
his dance moves got even better after
being on the competition show but that
didn't stop her from teasing him in
Milo's behind-the-scenes video he said
meg likes to do an impression of his
dance moves it was pretty hilarious but
he got her back these two best friends
aren't afraid to tease each other a
little it's all in good fun
[Music]
from everything the cast has said it
sounds like zombies - was a blast of
film it really helps when they are all
great friends j14 magazine sat down with
Meg Donnelly pierce Josa
Arielle Martin and Chandler Kitty they
asked him Megan the new actors about
their funniest moments on set apparently
they all spent their time laughing
Trevor Tordjman who plays Bucky is
apparently one of the funniest members
of the cast he likes to riff and improv
when he's off camera meg would cry from
laughing so hard
trevor has great comedic timing meg also
thought that it was hilarious watching
everyone dive into the mud for the song
we got
it was funny for the fans - another
hilarious moment behind the scenes
happened at dance rehearsal in the last
week of rehearsals
the werewolf dancers had to get used to
dancing in their wigs so they came to
practice in normal clothes and makeup
while wearing giant werewolf wig the
actors said it looks so funny since no
one else was in costume one of the most
powerful scenes in zombies - is the
dance number for flesh and bones this
song was amazing it was all about
standing up for yourself and loving
yourself for who you are we're all more
than flesh and bones the song also had
some deep political messages - milo
Manheim revealed that this song means
the most to him out of all of them it's
a really emotional song his character
Zed has a lot of fear he realizes that
he hates being a monster which he takes
out on Addison he has to get over that
Milo said that flesh and bones was the
turning point for his character that's
when Zed realizes that the werewolves
are more than just monsters and so is he
he really turns his attitude around
after that and fixes his bad decisions
we can really see his character turn it
around - Milo poured all of his emotions
into that number you're fierce proud
werewolves if they think we're monsters
we are monsters every time we see a cast
in an interview they act like they are
all best friends but it's more than
acting the cast of zombies is really
close how did they get to be such good
friends
the answer is game night in the first
movie the cast often had dance parties
together they continued that tradition
but I don't a bunch of board games to
the mix they all stayed at the same
hotel so they would get together and
play games they started this from the
very beginning of rehearsals everyone
talks about how much fun these nights
were there's the number one game that
they played was Bananagrams
the cast also had pool parties honestly
it sounds like filming zombies too was a
blast if they were not playing games or
spending time at the pool
they were always hanging out they'd even
go to the grocery store together just to
get some snacks the original cast
welcomed the new werewolves into the
fold right away Meg invited Pierce to
hang out the very first night they met
they were in the elevator and she
if he was coming to her room to hang out
he was a little taken aback but he
joined the rest of the cast he was part
of the pack from that night on one of
the themes from the first movie was
standing out from the status quo
Seabrook was all about conformity that
theme of individuality continued on in
zombies - but when you're filming
choreographed dance numbers it's hard to
be an individual everyone is doing the
same moves right not in zombies - the
choreographers and directors wanted
everyone's personality to shine through
the dance numbers they have the same
basic moves but they were free to add
their own personal spin everyone had
their own variation that made these
dance numbers even better this personal
touch extended into the costuming
Department the werewolves didn't fit in
with the humans or the zombies they are
totally unique
so Pierce Arielle and Chandler got to
have input in their costumes they had to
wear certain items but then they were
allowed to spice it up for their
characters we loved how much artistic
expression the actors were able to
uphold Zen Addison finally kissed in
zombies - but filming this on-screen
Peck wasn't easy keep watching for all
the details it can be daunting to be the
new kid on the block Arielle Martin said
that she had a lot of anxiety about
joining the cast she knew how close-knit
everyone was and then she had a delay
when getting to Toronto for rehearsals
she showed up three days late which made
her feel even more anxious she was
worried about not knowing the
choreography and how everyone would
treat her but she didn't have to worry
at all when she arrived Meg texted her
to welcome her to Canada Arielle told
Seventeen magazine that that helped a
lot she got to rehearsals early the next
day and ran into Chandler Pierce and Meg
they showed her the choreography that
she mesta so she wouldn't fall behind
the next day Arielle joined them for her
first game night once they spent time
hanging out she no longer felt worried
about fitting in it definitely helped
that her co-stars were so nice and
helpful our pack is our pack we don't
need anyone else
it wasn't just the older cast members
that would hang out together it can be
hard to be younger than a lot of people
on set
Kingston Foster who plays Zoey in the
movies is only nine years old
most of her co-stars are in their teens
or early 20s
but they didn't make her feel left out
at all Kingston bonded really well with
the werewolf actresses Arielle and
Chandler
she had a girls night with them they
baked cookies from scratch and had a ton
of fun she also said that they would
play a game where there were spies on
set we think it's great that the older
actors worked hard to include Kingston
and who can blame them she's an awesome
kid when you're playing a werewolf you
need a lot of makeup and sometimes stage
makeup can be a real hassle here's
Joseph who plays Wyatt said that his
makeup test took seven hours for the
test they try to figure out what works
and what doesn't and creating a werewolf
takes a long time he spent literally a
full day in the makeup chair while the
makeup artists work their magic
it didn't take seven hours every time
but putting on the werewolf makeup still
took a couple of hours everyday Pearce
also got freaked out by the acrylic
nails he was having a rough day and
hadn't eaten he didn't realize that they
glue giant acrylics on your nails before
they trim them he's said he nearly
passed out when he saw how long they
were and what about those glowing
werewolf eyes often actors will wear
colored contacts but not everyone can
handle them the movie avoided that issue
altogether the creepy eyes were all
added in post-production by video
editors
okay this is a little bit weird fans
were so excited that Zhen and Addison
finally had their first kiss it was so
sweet and romantic but they were just
acting there's nothing romantic about
filming this sort of scene Milo and Meg
are best friends in real life thankfully
that made them feel relaxed instead of
awkward but the logistics of kissing
on-screen are difficult it has to look
perfect on camera meg said that they
probably kissed about eight times to get
it just right in one take her nose look
too squished in another his face was
almost entirely covering hers they had
to work hard to line up their lips to
get the perfect shot yeah that's
definitely not romantic it may have
taken them several tries but they
finally got it there on screen smooch
was perfect even though it was one of
the last scenes in the movie it was shot
the first weekend of filming they got it
out of the way so it wasn't looming over
them what was your favorite moment from
zombies too let us know in the comments
below
we werewolves so admire your town and we
just came here to join your school
zombies to look like it was a blast to
film but things aren't always fun and
games Disney Channel stars have serious
guidelines they have to follow
especially when filming a highly
anticipated sequel like zombies - what
are the cast members allowed to post on
social media and which rule forced
actors to get their beauty sleep during
the day keep watching to find out the
ten strict rules the cast of zombies -
had to follow Disney Channel is really
serious about keeping their projects a
secret
they only release the details that they
want - there are never leaked photos or
videos from the set and the stars never
say anything they aren't supposed to
zombies - wasn't announced until
February 2019
just a year before the movie was set to
release Milo Manheim was given the honor
of announcing it
but that was the last anyone heard for a
while slowly we found out that there
would be werewolves in the movie and
that Addison and Ted would have some
drama but the cast wasn't allowed to
talk about anything else no one even
knew the true plot of the movie until it
was released the cast and crew are
prohibited from even sharing behind the
scenes photos until Disney says it's
okay they filmed all last summer but
they had to keep their social media on
lockdown it must be difficult to keep
such an exciting project under wraps
like that we are glad that the movie is
out so we can finally know what life was
like during the filming process if you
watch Meg Donnelly and Milo Manheim
being interviewed you'll notice that
they act a lot like Addison and Zed they
might actually be that peppy all the
time but Disney Channel has a rule for
their stars they have to keep up a
certain image around the clock it's
important for Disney that everything and
everyone fits into their brand part of
Disney Channel's brand is having
happy-go-lucky bubbly stars this means
that many Disney Channel stars have felt
like they have to hide their true selves
now we don't doubt that the cast of
zombies too is made up of fun wonderful
people but it can't be easy to always be
playing a part anytime they are on video
whether it's on their social media or in
an interview they have to act a certain
way many Disney Channel stars completely
rebrand themselves once their contracts
are up it will be interesting to see how
these stars turn out after their Disney
Channel days are over I'm so excited to
see
well one of the best parts of zombies -
is the dancing the dance numbers are
incredible it's a lot of fun watching
the cast break out into song and dance
but it takes a lot of work to make those
perfect dance routines look natural
before they ever started filming the
cast had to go to a dancing boot camp
they arrived in Vancouver a full four
weeks before the first day of shooting
and they spent long hours every single
day learning and perfecting the dance
routines actors who missed out on a day
had to catch up on their own Arielle
Martin had to arrive three days late to
rehearsals and she was nervous but Meg
and the other werewolves helped teach
her the choreography she had missed
we're glad she had such great cast mates
it would have been difficult to come
into rehearsal absolutely clueless the
actors spent the month learning those
dance numbers perfectly they were more
than ready by the time filming started
but it still took several takes for each
song they pulled it off though the
dancing looks completely natural in the
final cut the creative team for zombies
- had an amazing attention to detail and
a lot of effort went into making the
werewolves as authentic as possible in
typical werewolf lore werewolves can't
touch silver sometimes it causes slight
discomfort and in other stories its
fatal and zombies - the werewolves are
allergic to silver they couldn't have
any jewelry or accessories that even
look silver silver the werewolves and
the zombies were allowed to have some
say in their costumes they could add
their own Flair that they thought fit
the characters but if they accidentally
slipped on a silver ring the costume
team would freak out they also had to
deal with other makeup and costume
details these led to the werewolves
having to be in the makeup chair at
around 5 a.m. every
becoming a werewolf took about three
hours thankfully if the actors were good
sports about all of it but we know that
part couldn't have been fun I mean we're
jettison shippers were thrilled that Zed
and Addison finally took their
relationship to the next step in zombies
- at the end of the movie
those two locked lips fans everywhere
were thrilled but filming a scene like
that requires many guidelines the
kissing scene took about eight takes to
get just right first of all it's a
Disney Channel movie it can't be too
sensual or inappropriate but it also
needs to look authentic which can be a
difficult balance to strike then it has
to look good on camera in real life it's
not always glamorous but Megan Milo had
to be in exactly the right positions
Milo couldn't block her face too much
even though he is a lot taller than her
she had to make sure her nose didn't get
squished too that's why stars always say
that filming the perfect smooch is
anything but romantic there are a ton of
people around telling them how to get it
just right we're just glad it looks
natural and romantic in the final cut of
the movie not only is it important that
the Stars keep movie details under wraps
but they are also limited on anything
else they say Disney Channel stars
cannot criticize anything about the
movie or the company it's actually in
their contract and they can lose their
jobs if they do you'll notice from
interviews that the cast of zombies -
only has positive things to say about
the movie even when they talk about the
hectic filming schedule or getting their
makeup done they keep their comments on
the sunny side it was an amazing
experience well we're sure they did have
a great time filming a movie isn't
always rainbows and butterflies there
are things that aren't enjoyable just
like with any job because they work for
Disney Channel they can't say anything
bad
they can't even sound like they might be
criticizing the process Disney is
probably a little extreme when it comes
to this rule but they want all the fans
to think life as a Disney Channel star
is perfect what rule was actually
enjoyable for the zombies to cast keep
watching to find out we can crush it
maybe we can't make the rules but we can
break them
some Disney Channel movies have very few
scenes that take place at night but
that's not the case with zombies -
zombies and werewolves are creatures of
the night that means many of these
scenes and musical members had to be
filmed after the Sun went down we aren't
talking about a couple of hours after
dinner either
these filming sequences often took all
night even though many of the actors are
still kids
it didn't matter they had to be up late
all the time but they still had plenty
of scenes to film during the day - this
cast wasn't getting a lot of sleep
sometimes not everyone was required to
be on set it depended on which scene was
being filmed but in order to hang out
with each other many of them went to set
on their nights off if you're already
missing out on regular sleep you might
as well fully commit right the cast got
by on cat naps and caught up on sleep
during the day when possible becoming a
Disney Channel star means giving up a
lot of your individual freedom Disney
Channel contracts are strict and they
require actors to commit completely
Disney Channel even controls what the
Stars can post on their social media we
don't just mean post about the movies
they're in that's an important part of
it they can't post spoilers or any
behind-the-scenes details Disney doesn't
want leaked but the rest of their posts
are monitored by Disney - they can't
represent brands that Disney doesn't
approve of they can't post aspects of
their life that are too serious and they
can't be too controversial everything
they post on any platform has to fit the
image of a perfect Disney Channel star
even if it's not entirely true Disney
Channel even controls what its stars
wear in public they can't wear anything
deemed too appropriate or revealing even
on their own time this is the case for
every star including the cast of zombies
- you're beautiful at ease
zombies and zombies too are somewhat
different from other Disney Channel
original movies the cast of each movie
was allowed a degree of creative freedom
they wanted the characters to feel
authentic in zombies the zombies were
able to spice up the costumes they added
elements that they liked and wanted but
it had to fit a few guidelines first of
all it had to make sense for the
character it also had to fit with the
general vibe of the zombies costumes and
makeup zombie football star presidential
hopeful the werewolf's had the same
freedom with some restrictions anything
they added needed to fit a certain color
scheme and style but they could add
things to their costume the cast was
also allowed to add their own spin to
their dance moves as long as they
followed the general choreography they
could move their arms or legs in ways
that felt natural again
this had to fit their individual
character this creative freedom made all
the characters come alive and feel
original it was important because the
message of the franchise is that being
an individual matters Disney Channel
wants its cast members to be close
friends it helps boost their image of a
positive friendly company for kids and
teens so cast bonding is never
discouraged the zombies to cast took
this very seriously
a lot of their bonding moments were
self-imposed in the first movie they
hosted a bunch of dance parties they
continued that tradition on zombies too
they also hosted a bunch of game nights
after rehearsals or during time off
while filming they would play all sorts
of board games together they also had
pool parties the returning cast wasn't
about to exclude the werewolf's either
they were invited to hang out with
everyone on the very first day we'd love
that they are all such great friends it
also made the movie so much better
because they all had great chemistry
which rule would be the hardest for you
to follow let us know in the comments
that's a wrap give this video a thumbs
up and click that subscribe button
thanks for watching we'll see you next
time on the things
[Music]